just
trying to throw it away and didn't
was that because you were jostled as you
let it go or
yeah i was just trying to flick it out
of bounds didn't want to take a sack and
just uh shouldn't happen so you didn't
think you had drunk on that plane did
you do
yeah i was trying to get it out
[Music]
he said he tried to flick it maybe he
shouldn't have flicked it maybe maybe he
should have muscled
do you believe that's what he was doing
or did you just like kind of have one of
those moments one of those russell
wilson moments one of those jameis
winston moments did tom brady have one
of those moments i mean i i'll say
watching live i thought he did and as
i've watched the replays a bunch of
times too i still think he was trying to
throw that to rob gronkowski he's not
going to tell us that especially after
the gaffe at the end of the first half
last week against the dolphins and
number two the thing he's more scared
about than anything is he's got to deal
with this coaching staff tomorrow and if
they hear that he was trying to throw
that at the gronk they're just gonna
they're gonna roast him so uh but maybe
he was he was tied up either way it's
very rare where we see brady go back in
the pocket and even get in that position
and i think that's what's funny about
the patriots there's a lot of things the
last two weeks where we've never seen
them in this position or do these type
of things and messing up situational
football clearly we're not the better
team on the field yesterday and still
had a chance to win and just didn't come
through and when i say russell wilson
moment because you know how i feel about
russell wilson i'm talking about that
last monday night thing where it was
just twisted up yeah
does it more often wilson doesn't do it
all that often brady rarely does it but
now that it's happening in december when
we're used to seeing the patriots find
their groove when we're used to seeing
the patriots separate from situational
football to not making a bunch of stupid
decisions like committing 14 penalties
for 107 yards that's not what the
patriots do what do you think
fundamentally is wrong with the team
well i think they're a different team
than years past more than anything i
mean first of all i've never seen them
commit penalties the way they did
yesterday i think that's the first thing
that jumped out to me they're not able
to dissect you in the past game when
they spread the field out like they have
been able to in years past they want to
run the ball they want to run sony
michelle they want to pull guards they
want to run play-action pass off of that
and they've ran into a team yesterday
with the pittsburgh steelers who are big
and physical bigger and more physical
than the patriots are up front on both
sides of the football and yeah i think
between that you know between brady he
is 41 and he's no longer you know one of
the best quarterbacks in football he's
still really good and you can win a
super bowl but i think we're all seeing
some chinks in the armor here this year
uh i think all of those things are kind
of leading to what we're seeing right
now and
i don't i don't remember the afc ever
being so up for grabs ever here in
recent history patriots are now three
and five on the road that obviously ends
their road schedule for the year it's
the first time they've had a losing
record away from home since 2009 and
that doesn't bode well for the post
season because if they don't finish
higher than the three seed where they
currently sit they're going to have to
go on the road for at least the
divisional round and barring upsets for
the afc championship game if they even
get that far the last time they were not
higher than three
they got destroyed at home in the wild
card round by the baltimore rave and so
it's been every year since 2010 they've
been the two-seater to the one seed that
could be coming to an end and right now
it's out of their hands they need help
in order to get a buy and it's amazing
that we're saying that it is amazing i
mean the fact that you know i just don't
think we ever would have thought they
would lose two in a row in december it's
very rare uh the defense doing things
yesterday that i think i mean whether it
was big pass interference calls whether
it was letting somebody like jalen's
jalen samuels bounce outside on some
some big moments for some runs you never
see that the patriots are the kings of
what they call setting the edge they
make their outside linebacker defense
and
funnel the run back inside i mean that
will get you cut up in new england if
you don't do that on a regular basis and
they let that happen again last night
yeah they're they're another team that's
in a little bit of a funk right now as a
whole and uh the steelers
i'm still a believer in the steelers
mike i mean well look how wide open the
conference is
if they play like they played yesterday
they could beat anyone in the class i i
still look at them as one of the best
teams in the afc we don't even know if
they're going to get in the playoffs yet
but i do know that you know just
offensively and defensively you know
they're they're great on both sides of
the ball but it's all about whether they
can just limit those moments where they
screw up the game where they're winning
the game and they're driving and big ben
throws a dumb interception down the
middle of the field you know to the
duron harmon or missing a field goal
which they're doing the best at anybody
in football with boswell leading the
league and missed kicks this year so uh
that's where the steelers are
frustrating but i truly do believe that
they're one of the most talented teams
in the nfl i mean let's think about this
for a second between the steelers the
ravens the titans and the colts four
quality teams
two of them are getting in yeah two of
them aren't getting in right and between
the steelers and the ravens one
definitely is getting in but the one
that doesn't win the division
is not potentially getting in and it
could come down to titan's colts week 17
to determine the sixth seed there's
going to be a lot of tentacles and
interconnections in week 17
and who knows how this is all going to
play out for the last few spots but in a
year like this where it feels wide open
you punched that ticket to the sixth
seed or the five seed in week 17 you
could go to the super bowl go to the
super bowl and you could win it we've
seen it before we may see it again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports